now if you've been around software
engineering long enough you'll realize
that most of the technology that makes
up the web isn't really new or
cutting-edge it's actually old
technologies with new sometimes worse
names now I think atlases and sprite
sheets are a perfect point of this so a
sprite sheet in the html5 world it
actually describes that what we use as
an atlas but this is very very wrong see
back in the 2d days of making games
atlases were used to define many sorts
of charts in a single image where sprite
sheets was a term reserved just for
animated objects the sprite sheet
concept only really existed when you
needed particles to fly around or a
character to make a swipe with a sword
everything else was just an atlas now
for you web developers out there who are
actually using the term sprite sheet
incorrectly I forgive you but let's try
to fix that okay